اخر المستجدات كانت الغاره الاسرائيليه
التي استهدفت احد المنازل في منطقه
النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه قبل قليل هذا
المنزل اصيب من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه ولكن حتى الان غير معروف
نتيجه هذا القصف هل هو لمنزل ماهول تماما
كما السلسله التي سبقته خلال الساعات
القليله القادمه وبالتالي تكون نتائج
داميه كما كانت في الغارات التي سبقتها ام
ان الامر يتعلق بمنزل غير ماهول هذا كله
سوف يتضح خلال الدقائق القادمه بطبيعه
الحال باعتبار ان الغاره الاسرائيليه حصلت
او نفذت للتو ضد هذا المنزل لكن المنطقه
منطقه وسط قطاع غزه تعرضت الى سلسله من
الغارات من بينها استهداف منزل في منطقه
المغازي الامر الذي ادى الى استشهاد
واصابه العشرات من المواطنين الفلسطينيين
جراء هذا الاستهداف داف فضلا عن عده غارات
اسرائيليه استهدفت مناطق متعدده في وسط
قطاع غزه في دير البلح والبريج وهذا ياتي
جنبا الى جنب مع التوغل الاسرائيلي الذي
شهدته منطقه البريج شرق مخيم البريج وسط
قطاع غزه واقتحام جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لاحد مراكز الايواء مدرسه في
شرق المخيم وح واعتقال كل الرجال الذين
كانوا بداخله واحتجازهم ولا يعرف حتى الان
معلومات كثيره عن مصير هؤلاء النازحين
الذين كانوا داخل هذه المدرسه ويعد
بالمئات على ايه حال هذا الامر ياتي جنبا
الى جنب مع تصعيد واضح في وتيره القصف
الجوي بشكل عام خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه خصوصا في مناطق الوسط والجنوب
وتحديدا في منطقه رفح التي استهدفت بغاره
اسرائيليه ادت الى استشهاد 21 مواطن
فلسطيني واصابه اعداد اخرى بجراح وجميع
هؤلاء من اسر نزحت من منطقه خانيونس الى
منطقه رفح وذلك بناء على تصعيد الموقف
والغارات الاسرائيليه التي شهدتها منطقه
خانيونس وتحذيرات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
للسكان في بعض المربعات بضروره اخلاء
منازلهم والتوجه الى المناطق في منطقه رفح
لكن هذا القصف الاسرائيلي لاحقهم حتى في
تلك المناطق وهذه قصص تتكرر في كل يوم
الغاره الاخرى التي كانت اكثر
دمويه من بين الغارات الاخيره هي في منطقه
الفخاري الى الجنوب الشرقي من خان يونس
وهي ليست بعيده من محافظه رفح عندما
استهدف احد المنازل لعائله العمور الامر
الذي ادى الى استشهاد تسعه مواطنين واصابه
اخرين والحديث يدور عن اعداد كبيره كانت
داخل هذا المنزل ساعه استهدافه بالقصف وذا
ايضا هذا ياتي الى جانب سلسله من الغارات
الاسرائيليه والقصف المدفعي الذي استهدف
مناطق متعدده في قلب مدينه خان يونس وايضا
شرق مدينه خان يونس خلال الساعتين
الماضيتين يمكن الحديث عن اكثر من 40
شهيدا سقطوا خلال الساعتين الاخيرتين فقط
في عدد من الغارات الاسرائيليه استهدفت
رفح وخ يونس ومنطقه وسط قطاع غزه وهذا
بالتاكيد رقم كبير جدا ويشير الى تصعيد في
وتيره الغارات الاسرائيليه التي كانت خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه قد تراجعت وتيرتها
لصالح الطائرات المصيره التي كانت تنفذ
ضربات ضد اهداف متحركه سواء سيارات او
دراجات ناريه او للمواطنين الفلسطينيين
الذين يسيرون سيرا على الاقدام
ولمصلحته ال الذي استهدف عديد من المناطق
لا سما محيط منطقه او مستشفى الامل التابع
لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني والذي
استهدف هذا اليوم احد المنازل المجاوره
لهذا المقر ولهذه المستشفى الامر الذي ادى
الى سقوط اعداد كبيره من الشهداء والجرحى